soon resorts on the las vegas strip are
slowly recovering and today will the
cromwell reopen just a few hours ago it
opened its doors once again the last
strip resort that was still shuttered by
the pandemic
hector mejia live on the strip with the
details on the cromwell
opening once again hector good morning
or good afternoon
well hey there the cromwell spent seven
months with its doors
locked the general manager tells me that
around 350 workers are back
and more are returning as demand picks
up and here's how they celebrated
today's grand
[Applause]
reopening
the cromwell remained closed after
casinos were allowed to reopen while it
served as a covet free
bubble for the cbs reality dating show
love island
the winners from season two were here in
terms of changes you'll notice the
boutique hotel is following the same
safety measures
as the other properties that are also
part of caesar's entertainment
some slot machines have been turned off
and chairs spread out to allow more
space between guests
the sportsbook has half the chairs that
it used to have
the cromwell senior vpn general manager
explained why the property decided
to make a switch and cater to a specific
crowd from now on
we will be opening for 21 plus in all
areas of the property except for giada's
restaurant which will still be open to
all ages
um really the logic behind that is we've
positioned ourselves historically as a
really with the best odds and the
biggest wins for the gamer
you know we have some of the best
premier nightlife there's been a lot of
training that's been going on over the
last 48 hours to get everybody ready
what happened the gaming control board
has not allowed nightclubs and day clubs
to reopen yet
we're told dres is opening the former
dress after our space at stray's lounge
starting tomorrow night
the cromwell will stay open 24 7 for
both casino
and hotel guests and so this means that
every resort on the las vegas strip is
now open but that is not
the case across the valley just down the
road from here along flamingo the palms
and the rio
remain closed and there is no date to
reopen yet
that has been announced reporting from
the las vegas strip hector mejia
8 news now hector thank you very much